les ateliers les différents produits et
sur tous les postes à pourvoir
cette fois ce ne sont pas les candidats
qui cherchent à convaincre mais
l'entreprise qui veut donner envie à de
futurs salariés de postuler pour la
deuxième fois le fabricant de jouets
smoby organise un job dating
on se rend compte qu'on attire on attire
des gens qui sont peut-être pas inscrit
dans les agences qui ont envie de voir
comment l entreprise avant de postuler
de faire un cv voilà donc c'est une
démarche différente
je pense que c'est moins engageant aussi
une cinquantaine de personnes a fait le
déplacement pour cette journée de
recrutement
moi je suis nue plus par par curiosité
puisque c'est absolument pas mais mes
domaines de compétences mais bon
pourquoi pas je vais bien voir la suite
de l'entretien savoir si ci peut me
proposer quelque chose
après les présentations un entretien
d'embauché plus formel vous appréhendez
pas la conduite de chariots y compris
parce que on a plusieurs types
d'habilitation cette candidate cherchent
un emploi comme préparatrice de
commandes et al accepte d'être formés
pour évoluer
un profil qui intéressent
particulièrement la drh
l'entreprise est à la recherche d'une
cinquantaine de personnes en intérim
pour sa production de noël mais aussi de
personnel qualifié en cdi
de plus en plus difficile à trouver il
ya un certain nombre de personnes c'est
dans les prochaines années que ce soit
chez smoby mais aussi dans la plasturgie
d'une manière générale on ne discute
avec mes collègues et la problématique
est identique de nombreux départs en
retraite
un déséquilibre de nos pyramide des âges
et
il n'y a pas forcément les jeunes qui
sont allés vers ces formations pour
continuer de remplir ces ateliers
le fabricant de jouets compte faire la
promotion de la plasturgie notamment en
organisant des job dating deux fois par
an